it's yeah anything at all
yellow means calm down slow down I'm
solid jobless you need to stop with that
jealousy you know I do not like that I
cannot today because I love you you can
be jealous but be jealous on the inside
what is respect for you if I decide to
hug another American because that's our
custom that's what I'm gonna do you're
not it's hot no when I see your Arabic
people I'll say hi but when I see my
people it's my custom to do that cuz
it's no it's so wrong for you to try to
control me and tell me that my custom
and my culture is wrong you want me to
to save you it's okay go it's I come to
do it
Yas I'm talking about it again he really
got me pissed off like we just getting
back on good terms
I'm not planned that you're not gonna
talk to me like that like I'm a kid like
you're you control everything I do I got
my object I'm a person I'm a human being
I'm a person I'm a human being I
understand why you're angry you don't
respect me how I thought you did you
really don't you don't love me
cuz you don't want me to be myself no
you don't love me why the what I changed
my stuff I don't know why the what I
change myself you don't love me then if
you don't love Who I am and you want to
change every single little day don't
talk to me like that then
huh huh it's not funny to me because I'm
the one that keeps coming all across the
world sit comes the person who doesn't
care about me
[Music]